it's going to have David human another
mathematician thought that's interesting
right but you see how this kind of like
twists around and it does it there's
kind of two loops right like you turn
three turns again can we simplify this
thing and have a shape which is sort of
he wanted to get so much more elegant
but did accomplish the same purpose
right obviously I'm not going to break
up each one of these how many squares on
it
eighty-one squares I'm not going to
break each of those maybe one inch in
I'd but it could and you'd start to get
towards filling up the curve spilling up
that space right David Hilbert thought
so here's the Hilbert curve rather
subdivide into a three by three what
about this is what actually started Tory
first what I just doing it in a to fight
again loaded sideways you point through
this right here is the puck
then he'll bit traced out said again I'm
gonna start the bottom here up down
across it's the same principle isn't it
okay it's going up and down the aisles
but it's a simpler kind of shape one
three okay now even though it starts
since ah it actually lends itself to
something a little tricky this is one of
the reasons why I do the pyramid confess
I think it's one of the easiest to kind
of sink into the human curve something
interesting happens I need to subdivide
a bit further right so now we're gonna
do this twice
okay so the first time I had for this
next time I'm gonna have a 4x4 right you
see that okay now remember remember with
creating a fractal you creating
something with scale symmetry so just
like I put all these piano curves here
these nine piano curves in this order I
want to put these four yogurt curves in
this on one two three four now just
watch this for a second don't don't draw
it just watch what happens right if I
just copy this guy right into square
number one okay do you see I kind of
have a problem right do you see the
proper that's about if I want to match
the save and path but the original color
curve to you I need to go from here
and I've got to come on TV somehow but
I've ended in a corner which doesn't
doesn't let me there like you see that
so this orientation just having
identical doesn't actually serve the
purpose we want it doesn't fill the
space in a deep way okay so here's a
clever idea he said I'm just gonna turn
it I'm gonna start here at the bottom
but I want to get up to here right so
instead of going up I'm gonna go across
right that's still a Hilbert curve do
you see it it's still that same just
u-shape upside down U shape but now it's
orient in a way that gets me up to heat
you see that so gal just like I have my
soul food bridges he might be read just
gonna go here okay
yeah I'd like to start here look at the
original hilbert curve where is it going
to go it's going to go into the it wants
to go to the right okay so if I copied
this again and just went I'm in here
that's not a good place to go is it so
which way should I go first I should go
option mark one two three so there's my
original right now you can start to see
where this is going to finish I've got
to go 304 so I'm going to reach over to
here I'm gonna copy it again in the same
orientation and now I can finish off by
moving out to you for ya and you know
you've done it right because you know
you're done in a mathematically
intelligent way because of the symmetry
that you end up having okay now what
we're doing here this process of Gilbert
curves are the human curves for piano
curves of unica's it's cool if it has a
name it's called iteration each time way
it's a race okay I'm gonna let you try
to do this next one okay I'll give you a
start by saying we had a two by two then
a four by four this one's going to be an
eight by eight follow the path of our
second cubic curve and see if you could
get all the books of cramps okay okay
now as you're going through that it's
okay if you're not finished let me just
point out to you you all know you're on
the right track based on I have a look
at my bottom left-hand corner okay now
you can see my bottom left-hand corner
is oriented in exactly the same way as
my original Hilbert curve now what do
you think about it it has to be it must
be that way and I'll show you how I know
remember how as I thought about who
where do I go next
I've got one two three four and that's
how I did this one just like we had four
points to visit here I've got 16
here and the order is traced out by
video maker right fine
cease hate can't you see that
so what I've got down here is here's my
first one but I know I've got to go to
the way I've got to end on the right so
if I have got this orient in a different
way in work head - - and then my next
one has to be oriented this way so it
goes to three and then four and five and
six and seven and then eight nine
through sixteen are just the mirror
image okay which you should expect
because the original color curve is also
a mirror image once you get to the set
of top